>>> FOUR CHEFS STARTED OUT WITH
THE GOAL OF WOWING OUR JUDGES
USING THE INGREDIENTS IN THEIR
MYSTERY BASKET.
NOW ONLY TWO REMAIN, GEORGINA
AND CLAIR.
WHO WILL IT BE?
>> YOU DID SOME GREAT COOKING
OUT THERE.
I THINK EITHER ONE OF US COULD
WIN.
>> I THINK YOU COULD WIN OR I
COULD WIN.
>> THAT'S WHAT I JUST SAID.
>> JUDGES, THOSE WERE SOME
REALLY TRICKY BASKETS.
BUT AFTER THREE ROUNDS WHAT DO
YOU THINK?
>> WELL, GOING BACK TO THE
APPETIZER ROUND, CLAIR REALLY
MADE VERY GREAT USE OF THOSE
ARTICHOKE HEARTS.
>> YEAH, THEY WERE SO CRISPY.
>> YEAH, AND SHE WASN'T THROWN
BY THE LOOSE SUGAR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> BUT SHE HAD A HARDER TIME
WITH THE FIVE-POUND HORSE PENIS.
>> GEORGINA HAD PROBLEMS TOO.
HER APPETIZER WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
AN ARTICHOKE SLIDER.
>> YEAH, BUT IT WAS ACTUALLY
JUST A KITTEN ON A HAMBURGER
BUN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THE
SALAD?
>> HER SALAD SEEMED LIKE AN
AFTERTHOUGHT.
AND SHE OVERDRESSED IT.
>> YEAH, IT DIDN'T NEED THE FULL
TUXEDO.
JUST A TIE WOULD HAVE BEEN FINE.
>> AND CLAIR SEEMED TO BE JUST
PRETENDING TO WASH HER HANDS.
>> YEAH, SHE DIDN'T EVEN TOUCH
THE WATER.
>> LET'S MOVE ON TO THE MAIN
COURSE ROUND.
>> I THOUGHT THE WAY CLAIR
INCORPORATED THE MARSHMALLOW
FLUFF INTO HER STEAK SAUCE WAS
REALLY CLEVER.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
BUT, MY STEAK WAS RAW.
>> RAW LIKE THE TEMPERATURE OR
RAW LIKE IT HAD A MOUTH AND KEPT
USING THE "C" WORD?
>> THAT ONE.
>> OKAY.
>> GET A LOAD OF THESE
[ BLEEP ].
>> I THOUGHT GEORGINA SERVED A
REALLY NICE PLATE OF FOOD.
>> WELL, SHE SERVED ME DIVORCE
PAPERS.
AND NOW SHE HAS HALF OF
EVERYTHING.
>> BUT YOU HAVE FULL CUSTODY OF
HER KID.
>> YES.
>> BUT KID LIKE GOAT, RIGHT?
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT DESSERT.
>> YOU KNOW, GEORGINA WAS REALLY
DETERMINED SHE WAS GOING TO GET
TO THAT ICE CREAM MACHINE FIRST.
>> I JUST WISH SHE HAD
TRANSFORMED THE CANDY CIGARETTE.
BECAUSE SHE JUST STUCK IT IN THE
ICE CREAM.
>> YEAH, ALONG WITH SOME REAL
CIGARETTES.
>> SOUNDS LIKE YOU COULD MAKE A
CASE FOR EITHER ONE TO BE
"CHOPPED" CHAMPION.
>> BUT ONE STOOD OUT.
>> OKAY.
>> SO WHOSE DISH IS ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK?
CHEF GEORGINA, YOU'VE BEEN
CHOPPED.
>> YOU KNOW, I'M DEFINITELY
DISAPPOINTED, AND MAYBE I'M NOT
THE "CHOPPED" CHAMPION.
BUT I NEVER SIGNED A RELEASE.
SO Y'ALL CAN'T USE ANY OF THIS.
SUCK IT.
>> AND THAT MEANS CHEF CLAIR IS
THE NEW "CHOPPED" CHAMPION.
>> YES!
>> LET ME KNOW WHEN THE CAMERAS
ARE OFF.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]